The concept of Covalent Bonds is what we have
studied in detail in the
previous video.
We also concluded with a question asking what
type of
covalent bond is shared by carbon with other
atoms.
Is it a single or a double or even a triple
covalent bond?
How does the bond
formation by carbon take place?
Let us answer all the queries related to bond
formation by carbon in this video.
Let us begin with understanding the simple
structure of a carbon atom first.
As we know, it has four valence electrons.
That means sharing of all four
electrons is possible.
Thus, the valency of carbon is the most important
factor
for its amazing capacity to form bonds!
So if we have a monovalent element like Hydrogen,
how will the bond
formation take pace?
Wait a second….what do we mean by monovalent?
We
know Monos is one, and valent here refers
to valency!
That means elements
having the valency one.
It needs one electron for stability!
Coming back to our
discussion, how will the bond be formed?
This single carbon atom can share its four
valence electrons with four different
hydrogen atoms!
It makes sure that each hydrogen atom attains
stability by
having two electrons in its shell and even
carbon gets eight electrons in the
outermost shell.
How?
One electron from each hydrogen atom makes
four and
there are already four valence electrons with
carbon!
These sum up to attain
the octet state.
This is how a Methane molecule is formed!
A single carbon atom bonded with
four hydrogen atoms!
Each bond here is a single covalent bond.
This is how
single covalent bond formation between carbon
and any monovalent element
takes place.
Now let us talk about the double and triple
covalent bonds formed by carbon.
To understand this, we take a simple example
of the compound carbon dioxide
first.
Can you draw the typical molecular structure
of carbon dioxide?
Yes!
It appears somewhat like this!
Two oxygen molecules bonded with one
carbon atom.
How is this bond formed by the way?
We know that the valency
of oxygen is two while that of carbon is four.
That means out of the four valence electrons
two electrons will be shared with
one oxygen atom while the remaining two with
the second oxygen atom.
But sharing means both the atoms will participate
in the bond formation right?
That is why at the same time each oxygen atom
also shares two electrons with
carbon atom.
Such type of sharing enables the atoms to
attain stability.
Wait a
second…did you notice that there are four
electrons or simply two pairs of
electrons shared between each oxygen and carbon
atom?
Yes!
That makes it a double covalent bond right?
Absolutely!
Now lastly, we take the example of a triple
covalent interaction of carbon.
Have you ever come across the compound Hydrogen
cyanide?
Yes!
It is an extremely poisonous liquid used for
experiments in laboratories.
Do you know what its chemical composition
is?
It is HCN.
So do you know what the structure looks like?
It looks like this!
Yes!
One carbon atom attached to one hydrogen atom
and one nitrogen
atom.
Now if you notice, the valency of hydrogen
is one; that means one
electron of carbon is shared with this hydrogen
atom.
Moving to the other side, the electronic configuration
of nitrogen is 2 comma
5.
That means it needs three electrons to complete
its octet.
Right?
And we
have the carbon atom waiting to share its
three electrons!
But we know that
sharing involves electrons from both the atoms.
That is the reason why even
nitrogen contributes three electrons for participating
in the bond formation.
Remember, a covalent bond always requires
SHARING of electrons.
So that is how six electrons are shared between
these two atoms.
Thus, three
pairs of electrons gives rise to a triple
covalent bond between the carbon and
nitrogen atoms!
Now this was how carbon forms various covalent
bonds with other elements.
Is this the reason why carbon forms so many
compounds?
Well, this is
definitely one of the major reasons why carbon
compounds are widely found!
So what could be another reason?
One extremely important property of
carbon is to form bonds with ITSELF!
Yes!
A single carbon atom can form multiple bonds
with other carbon atoms to give
rise to massive carbon chains!
This property is called Catenation.
Let us understand the property of Catenation
in the upcoming video!